So, you got the user pool. Oh my
goodness. Okay. Let's make a new Damn.
Uh, okay. Let's make a new user pool.
Okay. Um,
so
on the a so on the search bar, just type
in Cognto.
Are you there already? Oh, you're there.
Okay. So, you're there already. Uh, hold
on. Let me get this expand this bigger.
There we are.
Okay. So, we're going to do a
traditional web application. We're not
doing anything big there. Okay. I'll go
ahead and So, name of your application.
You can name anything you want
there. Chewbacca app. I like that. See,
I could tell you're my student. Okay.
So, configuration option with sign in
identity. We're going to do email and
phone number.
Okay. And self-registration. Yeah. And
required attributes for sign up. Go
ahead and um click on that. And we don't
need to know your birth birthday date.
This is this. Okay. This is a little
lesson real quick about PII,
personal information. One of the best
things to uh be compliant with PII is
not to collect it in the first place.
So, you don't need to have somebody's
address or birth date. Um, even their
family name. You definitely don't need
to know their gender. That's some
cuckoo. All right. Um, the given name,
don't need to know that. Local or middle
name, you don't need that at all. So,
what you need is email.
Click on email
there. Scroll down. You need phone
number.
That's it. That's the easiest way of
being compliant.
Can I get their weight and height at
least?
Dress size.
Okay.
You know, Kevin would have been proud if
we would have put dress size up there.
Okay. So, return a URL. We don't need to
do that. Good. Go ahead and create the
user directory.
I always get this section like
navigating through here. I'm always
like, where am I going? I don't know.
No. No. Okay. So,
we have the user pool. Okay. Now, um
go to I always forget this part. Go to
view login page.
Okay. Yeah. Good. All right. Now, go
ahead and create an account. So, this is
where you do the registration for the
user. Okay. And go inside.
Uh, do a one first. Yep.
All right. Everyone, make sure to spam
TF US now.
There you go. Got your password. Confirm
the password.
Eva,
I'm waiting for a delivery. I hate FedEx
sometimes.
Feel like I'm prisoner.
Yep.
Okay.
Oh, no. No. No.
Now, if it didn't send the code to your
uh phone, basically within one minute,
if it hasn't sent, then resend the code.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Come here. Chewbaca. Come here.
I'm going to miss him.
Three weeks without three or four weeks
without Chewbacca.
Well, it's not going to be fun.
And then I'm going have five months
without him.
At least Chewbacca is gonna live a long
time.
Maybe Uncle Smith.
>> Did it send the code to your phone?
>> No, it did not.
>> Go ahead. Resend it.
Remember
last well earlier this week it would not
do the phone. We had to use the email.
>> Yeah, it'll definitely do SMS. It'll
this this part should work.
>> Shouldn't be that long.
So Chewbacca is a Yorkie poo. So like
the dogear calculations usually don't
work for him because he's longer lived
as a Yorkie poo. So he should make 18 to
20 years old.
>> Yeah.
>> So he's 11 right now. So I have between
six to eight more years with him
realistically. Yeah, it's it's not like
a linear thing. Like smaller dog breeds
usually live longer. Like my Shih Tzu is
like 17 years old. I don't think he'll
ever die,
>> right?
>> He's going to definitely live a long
time.
I'm going to miss you. You know that.
You know that, buddy. I'm gonna miss
you.
>> One thing I like about my um dog handler
is that she sends me photos every two or
three days from the other so I can see
what's going. Sometimes she puts a cam
up there, sometimes she puts a voice so
I can actually talk to them while I'm in
another country.
No code,
did you do your email? Did you do your
phone number?
Wow.
Okay. You can make another user.
You can make another user pool and only
do um email.
Yeah, that makes sense. What Bash said?
>> Is it SNS
dash or is it the other one?
>> Yeah, it was SNS essentially.
I think it was a slam box that came up.
I don't know. some sort of an error came
up for me and when I went down the
rabbit hole, it said that you had to
there's some sort of a sandbox that it
puts you in. You need to verify out of
that sandbox and then you also need to
purchase um an origin identity number
for US numbers or something. So, I mean
that some of that didn't apply to me, so
I didn't tug on that string too much,
but I just remember it was a hell of a
headache. So, I just did the email only.
Um but it me to do all of that. You'll
ask me to jump through some loops to to
uh configure SMS.
>> Yeah, it says so in the developer guide
it says some uh cognto events
>> create create create
an account. Yeah, there you go.
>> I'll just put in the chat.
This answers it pretty much in the first
paragraph.
Okay. What's your email?
Everybody look. Don't look at his email
on the screen. I don't want to know. I
don't know what to
>> look like on my phone.
>> You got a lot of cute doggy photos. I'm
sure
cute furry little doggy photos on your
email. I'm sure.
There you go.
>> Wow.
>> So, so it is uh
>> Yeah. So, you either either need SNS,
SES or
enduser messaging is apparently another
service. It looks like a different kinds
of configurations. It's just that's like
for developers to test. If the settings
are right, it won't actually send a
text.
So, we got this section done.
Okay. So,
you can now you know you can log in that
works in your environment, right? That's
good. This is this is very good. Um,
we could have fun. Want to have some
fun?
>> Sure. Um, and it says the view login
page.
>> Go ahead and open that up again. Open up
another tab.
You can put that.
You can sign in. You can say sign in as
different user.
So, nah, it's not. Well, if you if you
really want to. So just so you know, you
can give that link to the class if you
want to and other people can log in.
They can make accounts on there, not
just you. It doesn't know if it's you or
not. So it could be anyone, but they
want to if you want to have fun with
that. Um
Ron, who is this person?
Seems like a smart person
nerd. See, this is a smart guy.
>> Nope. That's just a nope.
Oh, who who is this? Okay. What do you
want, Serge?
>> Okay. Yes. Quick PSA. Right.
A lot of the guys Well, most of the guys
in the group are effing weird.
You guys are weird. If you go if you go
to an interview, right, and and you
mention a project, you must know what
problem you are trying to solve and the
challenges. If you said you migrated
from ECS to EKS on your resume, know
what problem you are trying to solve.
That is very very important cuz if you
don't know that doing a during an
interview, you are done.
I'm saying that because it happened to
someone.
>> So wait, we can't just [ __ ] and put
random [ __ ] on our our resume.
>> You can put random [ __ ] but at least
have a fallback. If you if Okay, if you
Okay, a simple one. If you are migrating
from ECS to EKS, they ask you what
problem you are trying to solve. Hey,
the company acquired another company
that was that use ECS and uh they wanted
to bring everything to Kubernetes
because that's what we use and also
compliance reasons. You could say cost
savings. Those are simple go-to, but do
not just go blank. Oh, what problem you
trying to solve? And you just you go
straight into gibberish. That is weird
and it makes you look stupid.
Yep.
>> So, learn the art of BSing. It's it's
it's better that you know what problem
they you were trying to solve with the
project and not know too much about the
technology then know a lot about the
technology and you have no idea what the
problem was because that screams fake
and made up.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. How about the next one? Well, AI
said this was a good idea.
>> If AI said this was a good idea, I could
ask, "Hey, AI,
uh, give me scenarios
and stories that that match with my
resume."
It's very simple. Here's one for the for
the agent core client. when I was in the
assessment with them, they asked me,
"Hey, we know that Agent Core is a new
service and, uh, we don't expect you to,
you know, be great at it. So, uh, have
you worked with Agent Core? What have
you done?" So, I told him, I said, "Yes,
I have worked with Agent Core and, um, I
created a a platform for our company and
it's for internal use only. It's not
it's not public facing, it's just for
internal use." That's why I worked on
and then they asked me about uh agent
core and uh the services
I was able to answer them
but the thing is I was quick and if you
are bsing oh this is this is something
else I've noticed with millennials
millennials will would start loading
when you ask them a question it's the
weirdest thing they'll just breeze that
happened three times
And uh someone told me that was an issue
with millennials. So yesterday when I
was talking to the uh S engineer for the
EKS project, he's supposed to set up the
pipeline. I give him the code base and
while we on the core, there was five of
us. I asked him a question.
Complete silence.
Nothing. I waited for I think one or two
minutes and they ask me, "Can you guys
hear me? Did my screen freeze? They're
like, "Oh yeah, we can hear you." And uh
the SO finally answered.
And then I spoke to a friend about that
with millennials just stuck unloading.
Ask him about I told him I told him
about what happened. He says his son
does the same thing. He'll he'll uh say
something to him and he'll just stay
there and load
>> and not say anything. No
acknowledgement, no nothing.
>> Yeah. I've not Okay. So, I've noticed
that kind of situation. I'm Gen Xer. And
of course, in my generation,
>> Gen Z, not not millennials, sorry. Gen
Z.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, um for us, if we like
didn't give an answer or we didn't move,
it was a death sentence.
Like literally, the parents would go
against us or a teacher would go against
us. Sometimes it' be physical. There was
no way to escape at all. So we we know
to engage for self-preservation.
We know the heat's coming at us, right?
So that's why prepared for this. But um
millennials and Gen Z's largely were
coddled in this area and they're not
aware of a true death sentence coming.
So, this is why I think like the job
cuts in uh the economy right now are so
hard for that generation because they're
not ready for hell. They were really
protected from it. Whereas Gen X was not
protected as a child. We we got the
blunt in the beginning. So, we're like,
"Yep, we're ready." Yeah.
>> Yes, that is correct.
>> You said they're not ready for hell or
help.
>> They're not ready for hell.
>> Okay. They're not they're not ready for
anything that requires work
or or discipline.
>> Yeah. That's why like to be honest like
a little bit I was worried about the job
market as a Gen Xer and whether or not
there would be an age discrimination. So
I was a little bit worried about not
that much but just a little bit. And
then where I saw Gen Z basically being
unable to go into the workforce, I was
like, "Oh,
I just got 10 more years of guaranteed
labor. Okay, I'll deal with that. I'll
just keep on working.
I'll have plenty of work because I can
read and I can actually do things. Okay.
Yeah, I can go to I go to another
country now. I don't need to use my
trust fun. I can just use that. Like I
can just I can uh get on the airplane
and go." So, yeah. Anyway, good comment.
Uh guys, uh everyone just so you know,
we all
>> there's something else too.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> The other one too, the one of the main
one, the introduction. When the
companies ask you to tell me about
yourself, they just they just have
diarrhea of the mouth.
It's like I've told people
practice practice practice your in
intro. you you should be able to say it
in your sleep and make yourself look
good. And my intro is the same intro. I
don't care who I'm who I'm speaking to.
It could be uh it could be uh hiring
manager uh AWS or even my team. Same
damn intro and they all love it.
Yep. Yeah. I have pretty much I have a
standard intro for my for my interviews.
It's really fun. I've been a really
engaging one. So, um, but the the big
one is,
uh, if you just sit there and stutter,
you look weird.
>> Go ahead.
>> You just do. And this is why, again, why
do I why do I teach mainly people who
are red pill? Because a lot of the
people who are red pill, you're supposed
to have game theory. You're supposed to
know how to talk up women. Well, if you
know how to talk up a woman, you know
how to do an interview.
It's not the two technologies are not
that different.
>> I said a lot a lot of people who are red
pill these days are it's like it's like
church for them.
>> They're they're fake red pill actually.
They don't understand the real
logic behind it.
>> Like
and then the other the other thing too,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Take time. take time to learn how to
interview. I know uh um I spent I spent
uh over over four months just uh
learning how to interview. I I was
spending over five hours a day.
>> Yeah, learn how to interview. Um again
for me just to be honest I learned how
to uh effectively learn the uh interview
in the United States when I had cancer
and uh it was a life and for me it was a
life and death issue and I had to use
Indian recruiters in order to teach me
how to interview and I had no idea if my
HP contract was just going to to
disappear tomorrow or not literally. So,
I went about five months that way, five
or six months, and the contract did end
like as I thought it was going to. And I
knew how to interview and I my costs
were low, so I was okay. So,
>> yeah. Correct. And then and then the
stories when they ask when they ask,
"Hey, tell me about your dayto-day. Tell
me what about what you do at work and
things like that." Look at the damn JD,
look at their pinpoint and tell them a
story. And the story format is very
simple. Create a disaster.
Then you saw it. Awareness, you fixed
it. Documentation and train your team.
If you follow that process, do not go
deep into technical. If you follow that
process, they'll love it.
>> Yeah. Do during during my interviews, I
I spend like 30 minutes just telling
them stories. And it's the same damn
stories for one of the jobs when I left.
Three interviews, three different
interviewers. Same damn stories. Same
three stories.
Yeah, it's not hard, guys. Yeah.
Listen to what Sergino is saying. He
knows what they're talking about. So
does Jules. knows what they're talking
about.
Listen, it's very effective. All right,
gotta keep on going with this.
Um,
>> no, that was my PSA. I'm still a little
pissed by someone screwing up an
interview,
>> sir. Okay. Um, hold on. Um, TIQS go back
to your uh, cogno console and for you
Sergino, what I have found is
there's a sizable amount of students who
literally need to be absolutely crushed
and humiliated by the interview process
before they will listen to anyone's
advice.
>> And even then, some of them still won't
listen.
>> I just sit back and say, "So be it." uh
and just the way it was. I mean
for me again like I told you guys it was
life and death for me. I could not play
around. Okay. So what's the development
platform for your web app? Uh go and put
Python on there.
It should be done. Go ahead and scroll
down.
>> You know I don't even think we got to
this point on Tuesday. We just tried to
get the verification working via the
command line.
>> So we don't need to do this.
>> Yeah. Get the token.
>> Yeah, do the to do the token part and
get proof that people can do the token
part so that we can then move on to do
doing other stuff because got to get the
token.
>> Okay. So,
where is he? We allow password policy.
Okay. So, let's go back to the user
pool.
User. Yep.
Go to the new one. You did 16 minutes.
Yep. Let's go to that one. Okay. So,
what we want to do here is policy. Make
sure that's correct. Um,
set up. No, we don't want that one. Um,
let's go ahead and set up MFA.
So when we set up the FBM options for
choice while
word passwordless status go ahead and
edit that one
and
set email message one time password
and say yes
changes
and Then multiffactor authentication say
yes there
say yes required MFA
and authenticator apps
and hold out email message also
uh
okay no let's not get rid of Oh that's
right okay get rid of the email uh
message for
Yep. Go ahead. Same changes.
What the hell?
Only password and web authent.
Okay. Password and web authent. Okay. Uh
let's go back. What did I do wrong here?
Let's go back. Sign in.
Okay. So, password.
Okay. Available. Oh, I know. Okay.
Options for choice based login. Click
that. Edit that. Uh, email message
onetime password. Remove that.
Okay. Go ahead and save changes.
Yeah, I tried to get a little
sophisticated. Um, MFA authentication
now required. Yep. And yeah, I thought
Yep, dude. Now do it,
bastards. Okay. Device tracking. Scroll
down. No. No. User account. This should
be fine. Scroll down.
>> So, what are you trying to do?
>> Or do MFA.
>> Yeah. Then quite MFA. Yeah. Then TIQS
you already create your MFA account.
>> Well, when he logs in again, it
shouldn't require the MFA to be
>> Yeah, it will. So, no. Yeah, it will.
>> Yeah. So, go ahead and now sign back in.
Go. Go to tab. Go ahead and refresh that
one.
Okay. And sign in.
>> Now we got good. Now it pass.
So this is something you can say in your
resume guys. You actually configured MFA
before Camino. There's something that
they like. So I was saying
companies need this.
Okay. I think somebody's at the front
door. Can you continue walking him
through that? Right back.
Yeah. So,
enter code from the MFA
and any any authentic care app you guys
choose should be fine.
Okay. So, that's good. So,
at this point, you're
ready ready to try to sign in
uh using the um
using the command line. So, head back
into the you Cognto user pool.
Okay. So, yep. So, user pool and then
click on user pool-fo
that one right there. Okay.
So, you have a user pool ID. Uh, which
is good. You have token sign in key URL.
It's probably new. Um,
scroll down.
Uh at sign in at threat protection
okay
we went to app clients. Uh
so he had Okay. So click on app clients
first.
Okay. So you'll need this client if
we're going to be doing this through
command line. You'll need this client
ID. So, just copy that down. So, on your
notepad.
Okay. So, and then once that's copied,
then click on Chewbacca app 2
and then copy this client secret as
well.
You'll need that as well.
Okay.
All right. And then
uh quick setup attribute page new.
Uh okay.
So we have so we have that
and Okay. So, so this is what I was
looking for. Authentication flows. So,
put your mouse over each one of these
authentication flows. So, choice secure.
Yeah, click on it
and yeah, left click on one. So, this
allow user o that's that's one flow. So,
click on the next one. Secure remote
password. So this is allowing for you
allow user srp.
That's fine. And then click on the third
one.
Allow refresh token on. Okay.
Okay. So
deal did deal did today different.
That's fine. Um let's see here. Okay. So
let me open. Sounds like we're doing it
live.
>> Say again.
>> Sounds like we're doing it live.
>> We're doing it live like we usually do.
All right. So,
open mine up
because the main thing that I want to
have TIQS have access to is the um is a
username password authentication
so that he can then Okay. Ah. Oh, it's
my thing is blocking it. Okay. Uh, so
scroll up a scroll up just a tad.
Hit edit in in this block right here.
Yep. Okay. So, here's what we want. So,
we have So, right now, what we have
checked off is allow user a. This was
the first thing that this was this was
what we started trying to do on Tuesday.
it that do we can we can get it done
this way but it will create three
separate prompts that we have to prepare
for or wait it'll create an an extra
prompt that we have to prepare for and
that's too much. Um here's the one that
we know works. So sign it will allow
user password.
This is the one that we know works
because we do this one and then we then
we get MF we should get an MFA challenge
response and then we get the active
session. Um and then I think Bash saw
one other uh
uh uh value here that we should change
regarding uh how active the session is.
Uh any info on that, Bash?
>> Yeah. Um basically it's if you go a bit
further down.
>> Yeah, that's it. Authentication flow
session duration. So it's currently set
to a default of 3 minutes. The max is 15
minutes. Just bump it up to 15 just for
your own benefit. It's just allowed.
We're just testing it. So yeah, this
gives you enough time basically to have
all the turnar around and any unexpected
[ __ ] that comes up.
>> Yeah. So this so whenever we are doing
this lab, we'll get some output and
we'll also get a session token and we
have to copy that session token into the
next response.
And if if we're not fast enough, then
the session token expires and then we
have to regenerate the a new session
token and it can get cumbersome. So
that's why bashes uh made it 15 minutes.
Uh okay. And then scroll down and save
this.
Okay.
All righty. So first things first uh we
need to get the um so it's MFA enabled.
So we need to
we need to get we need to get that hash
right Aaron the Python file.
>> Uh yeah.
>> Okay. So let me
let me get that uh where's that? Oh
right here. Well, let him I mean, you
could let him run into the issue and
open the docs and
>> All right. So, let's go with MFA
enabled. All right. So, I'll put I'll
paste this in the chat for you so that
you have the uh the code
first
of code in it.
Okay. Then I will also give you
the
uh the documentation.
There you go.
Authenticator.
Okay. So yeah, you can just open up any
your preferred code
uh terminal whether it be likely get git
bash. So yeah, open up git bash and then
uh all we see is your browser. So if you
have it open and you're showing us that
appreciate but we can't see it. All
right,
fixed it.
All All right.
Okay. Do we have to do the secret hash?
Okay. Oh, so that means we have to have
the um
the secret hash. Okay. So, we can't we
can't even do the init because we need
the hash. Okay.
So,
Okay.
So I'll put another link in for little
with in the chat.
And so the second link is just
documentation
and how to fix the secret hash.
Basically is you creating a um a Python
file on your machine.
So you have Python
which is good. Then
everything in that code block uh copy
it, paste into a um a file
and then um you would have to change the
well just paste into a file. Then we can
um work then we can start making
changes.
All
right.
So we have
username,
app client ID
and key. So username is the username of
the user
you want to have.
So I think it will be Chewbacca.
The app client ID
is whatever the app client ID is and the
key is the um the the app secret.
Yep. And then the then the last one is
the key. And the key is going to be your
uh the quiet secret. Yep.
Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Undo.
Undo. You want to get rid of key, not
the cis.org.
Yep.
Okay.
So then message key
uh
before I tell you to do anything else
let me verify one second
the
Yeah. Okay. And then that's that's the
note. Okay. So that was correct. That's
because that's a note. Put username with
the username of the user app client ID
with user pools app client ID and key
with your app client secret. And then
uh and then to get the hash you have to
run Python then the file name and then
you have to fill in the three values
again.
and Bash put some code that allows you
to do the conversion without um making a
Python file,
which is good.
I think the Python file is simpler to at
least understand what it's doing.
I don't like OpenSS.
It might just be Python instead of
Python 3.
>> Yeah, if it's on Windows,
>> invalid imaginary
liberal.
You may have to put the uh you may have
to put it in quotes inside of the file.
>> What's that?
>> I said you may have to put the uh the
strings in quotes
in order to make it work in Python.
>> No, no, no. You don't edit the Python
script.
>> I was I was That's why I was raising my
hand. I don't When I look at my script
and I look at what I did, we kept the
the the Python script the exact same.
>> Yeah. Go to the do go to the
documentation. You found it. It shows
you how to use it.
>> Right there. See on three.
>> It's written with like the AR library.
>> See? So hold on. Right there it shows
you
>> where it says number three. You did have
the right idea by changing that around
to match what your account is configured
for. But the actual script itself should
be the same.
>> See uh argv
that's the system like subm module for
grabbing arguments.
So this is the format of the command.
So you do Python or Python 3 name of the
script and then your username
the app client ID
and then the uh client C.
Also, if you hold down the control key
and then press the left or right arrow,
you get to skip the whole word.
>> Makes it makes it easier to navigate.
>> I look I remember I looked that up for
Alex cuz he did not like uh
having to skip to the beginning of the
line by holding the left arrow. Did you
uh
you you don't have to call it that.
Hash.py works fine. But
>> yeah, it just has to match what
>> you use. Python 3 again.
>> Yeah. So, whatever name that you name
it, it's fine. It's just
>> in your script though. Why does it say
Chewbacca?
>> Cuz that's is the us the user of his
cognito. I guess.
>> But he But you don't edit the script.
>> Okay. I told him to do that. That's on
me.
>> Yeah. You see like if it had variables
listed here like like let me like show
you. Hold on. Like see here. So this is
like a function
and this function is saying it's going
to get uh arguments from position uh one
two uh one two three and four but I
don't think it it's not inclusive of one
of them. So it's three arguments
and then it saves it to these
uh yeah it's an array uh but like these
are the different uh values that are
going to get set.
So it it's like um
well like in bash you know you could
have arguments so you can just do like
the script name and then you know space
and then something space something space
something
so you don't have to edit it.
It ironically is to make it easier to
use.
No. uh bash it it's they're not they're
arguments from the user but it's from
the system module
just the built-in one Python.
>> Yeah. So I was off base on that one.
>> That's right. And then you
>> but I mean I mean you could if you
deleted like the arg function and just
set each one and made a wrote a list
here it would probably work.
Okay. So I think you're ready to to let
it rip.
So, so what you've done is is right
previously.
>> You just need to press up on the
keyboard and then delete the three on
Python.
>> Yeah, because when you did Python hash
py, you got actual uh output.
So, press up on the keyboard.
Okay. Press down one.
Okay. Get rid of Python. Get rid of
three in Python 3.
Then press enter.
There's your ass.
Now
>> don't get that leading white space.
>> Oh yeah. Leading white space.
But now that you have this hash, the
hash
and you guys will see in documentation,
but that secret hash is included with
every single
API request or API call
when you're talking back and forth with
Cognto.
So,
So now if you try to uh do the cogn AWS
cognto initialize
then
okay so you you see where it has so hold
up real quick hold up so we're here so
we don't need to move just yet. So user
password o that's fine. Client ID that's
fine. O parameters. So you have user
Chewbacca 1 password Chewbacca 34 and
after the four that's where you want to
do a comma and then secret underscore
hash.
So, so all caps.
>> Do you like maybe could like Does he
have the documentation open so he can
see where we're getting this?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, nope, nope.
So, so I would I would look at
what uh what flags are already placed
inside of your um of your of that sample
that you got. So you have AWS cognto
initiate
you have your artflow
you have your client ID
you have your odd parameter
Okay,
you think that's good to go? Then let it
rip.
Give me one second.
on the right pens. You
That No.
Can you tell us what the username is?
Got it.
That's it.
Is there a way for users to verify what
the pass what the username is?
So, did you figure out the username?
>> I tried both.
So, I tried
>> that one first. It didn't work.
>> Did you get a different error?
>> Yes. Okay.
>> Is it still saying the username's wrong?
>> No, it's saying my hash is wrong now.
What values did you use to create the
first hash?
>> I used
that there.
>> Okay.
Are you using Chewbacca one as a
username?
I use that one.
I was going to say TIQS. Um, yeah, go
back to the um,
>> brother, go back to the use, you need to
get your user pool ID. So, if you go
back to the console,
>> okay,
>> I have a way that you can find it out.
>> Okay,
>> so if we go to the user pool ID, so that
means go to user pool.
>> Mhm.
Right click on the right user pool.
It's it's there as well. You see it was
there. Just Yeah, just copy that user
pool ID.
All right. So,
if you run this, it will tell you
just um I've got placeholders here. So,
just basically put the correct values
in.
So if you run that it should give you
back uh JSON
that will have your username
and use this as well.
So you need to put the region and you
need to put your ID that you just
copied.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah. There you go.
So username is that
>> okay I know what I did.
>> Yeah.
When
>> I ran this I ran it with the wrong
username.
>> Ah
>> that's what I did.
Wait
>> username.
Yeah, that's that's the username. Yeah,
>> without the quotation marks.
>> Tiq, do both usernames have the multi-
um factor authentication
set up?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
Turn.
There a comma in your username?
No,
>> because you have a comma in it when you
ran the Python script.
Oh [ __ ]
Hey, that one worked.
>> We're done.
Now you have to provide the software
MFA.
Did you want me
to change zooms?
>> Okay, guys, real quick. So, I want you
guys to continue doing this. I think you
guys are doing excellent work. So,
very good job. Um, shout out to Rob for
having his own Zoom account. I want
everyone here who is is in seven class 7
to go into Rob Zoom like continue
working continue troubleshooting this
don't worry about class 7.5 that's of
easier and smaller significance compared
to what you guys are doing here this is
by far more possible so you have you
have time to do global load balancers
who cares about that um so go off go off
and do that and I need this Zoom
environment to keep
All right.
>> Okay.
>> And the link Rob put the link in the
Zoom chat, so he's going to go over
there and spin that up. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> You guys are doing very well. Actually,
I just sat back and watched and I was
like, "Holy shit." So, uh, and my toy
hasn't arrived yet, so I'm still waiting
for my
>> All right.
>> All right. So, keep on going. make sure
you guys can get this. Actually using
the token and generating that token is
of extreme value for the interview,
not just for the job. Being able to
describe this this is prime interview
material. Okay. Um I'm going to drop
Does everybody have the the Zoom link?
Did you click on the other Zoom link?
>> Everybody do it.
>> I'll put it inside of G chat because I
know someone is going to say, "Hey, what
happened?" So
>> of course
>> I'll put in a G check.
>> I was asleep. I was with Chewbacca. All
right,
>> I'll see you guys. Guys are doing great
and I'll see you guys later. Okay, John.
either.
Yeah, of course. So, MFA is whatever is
um whatever your phone's MFA is, but
it's a on 30 second timer, so you know,
you just have to be quick with it.
Okay, then she
I don't fix that one last. is going to
expire.
>> Yep, that's fine.
And if you're able to complete this,
then put it put a uh screenshot in the
chat. So, we have you screenshot in the
chat or screenshot in the G check uh
chat.
A
>> second. He's about to reset.
Okay.
So, now you can throw that into Git Bash
and let's see what we get.
Oh yeah, we got to copy that as well.
Okay, so yeah, that'll be the last one.
So this entire session right here.
>> Oh shoot. Okay,
>> we got we got to copy this, too. But
that's fine. That's not too too bad.
So it's it'll be another flag after
after um the parameters
or after the challenge responses I mean
>> yeah it'll be
>> space
uh dash dash session
and then this this whole string
>> good god
session equal. Oh uh yeah no you can
just do session space
uh paste. Well actually no you don't
want to do session like that cuz session
session is its own flag. See here when
you have challenge name challenge
responses and then you have the map
string then you get a comma session is
its own flag. So keeping it like that is
fine.
>> Okay.
So session space and then you can paste
the session.
No, you don't have to do equal sign for
session. You can just do session space
and then paste
and then try again. Oh, you may have to
do your um your MFA.
>> Change my MFA code again.
>> Yep.
>> Oh, good. Just reset.
>> Good. Now you have an access token and a
refresh token and ID token.
Good. Paste that inside of the G check
chat because that's that is a a big part
of your homework.
Good.
Oh, what's the odd? Oh, it's been 15
minutes.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> So, so now you have the the full flow.
So, now it's just redoing all the
requests again and uh with the Yep. So,
Cornado initiate art rerunning the uh
request again. Okay. So I get token get
your session.
I got a national quote. They'll fix
that.
Uh just be aware TIQS. Yeah.
>> Yep.
Code
And that's what we want. Good. Why do we
know this worked? Because we have access
token. We have the
uh expires. We have token type, refresh
token, ID token.
So this works.
Why is this important? Because
at because now we're able to
generate these authentication tokens for
act for access based for for access
policy. Uh so when we now have requests
coming into the API gateway, we can have
signed requests coming into the the uh
signed or validated requests through
Cognto going to the API gateway, which
means it's it's traffic that we want to
be there for sure. for sure. As opposed
to traffic that made it through that's
but shouldn't but should not have been
there.
Oh,
this is good. It's very good. So, I know
that Joe has posted his posted his
screenshot in the chat. Um, I would like
other people to also post their
screenshots of them finishing the lab in
the chat so that we can all do the hip
hip parade.
Cool.
Yep. Yep. Okay. Post it in the chat and
then also post it in the
uh Yep. You post on in chat on Tuesday.
Cool. So, okay. Got three more. Awesome.
Yep. Interesting. Okay. So yeah, post
that in there as well.
Beautiful.
Okay. So
So this is good. So now Okay.
>> Do you want us to post it in in the chat
here or the group chat?
>> Both.
>> Okay, you got it.
>> Thank you.
>> No problem. Thank you.
>> Okay. Who else had is struggling with
this or needs help? Because
this this is not
this this this is this is a bit of a
challenge. More is more reading than
anything, but
um it's not too bad when you get the
hang of it.
So,
um,
does anyone need help at with this
or are we good to start tearing down?
Uh, Kevin, what's up?
>> Yeah. Um, I need help.
>> Then share screen. Let's take a look.
>> Which one is it?
I think it's this one.
Okay.
Okay. Um
>> Okay.
>> I might have messed up the format. Um
>> Oh. Oh. Oh, hold on. So, so you p So,
you copy and pasted um the session.
>> Yes.
>> Um Okay.
I have found that on occasion
for whatever reason there are weird
enter
uh characters put into the session.
>> So that so if you get tripped up on that
I wouldn't I won't blame you cuz that
happened to me when I was doing the app.
But I cut you off. What's what are you
what are you seeing?
>> Okay. Um, so when I enter this actually
I need to change the code.
>> Yep.
Wait. So you did you did the Python. You
got So you were able you were able to
get the hash?
>> Uh, yes.
>> Okay. So did you do So now you you got
the hash. Did you do the initialize
initiate authentication?
>> I'm pretty sure I did. I just wanted to
go back to see if my hash um
expired or Okay,
>> the the secret hash doesn't expire. The
the session may expire, but the secret
hash doesn't expire.
>> So, if I hit this
Uh, EBP. Yep. So, your session expired.
>> Okay. So, I got it started. Started from
scratch then.
>> Well, you Well, you're halfway there.
So, just copy in that session
and then paste it to
>> your
challenge.
Say again.
Okay.
>> Then from there now you can try to do
the respond to off challenge with your
credentials.
>> Okay.
Uh also the uh the code behind
I would say get rid of all the
backslashes and just use the normal
Terraform flags. It's not something
really.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. So, so if you So, yeah.
So, the secret hash is also include. So,
it was a space. So, the secret hash ends
in a equal sign.
>> And then you have equal sign slash which
means the secret hash thinks that this
goes together. It doesn't. So it has to
be uh equal sign space slash
wrong way
is
critical. So try copying everything over
again and now you uh give yeah try
copying the whole block and see if that
works.
Yes.
>> Invalid code. Oh, so you have to update
your code. 30 seconds.
Okay. So it was So I I guess I messed up
with the with the slash.
>> Yeah. So the slashes is that is not is
good when you're you know if you want to
be fancy a bit fancier. Um TIQS didn't
do it but I'm not going to say that you
should not do it either. It's just a m
matter of preference and style.
>> Basically that creates a new line. But
if you miss that space
uh forward space forward slash or space
back slash, however you want to say it,
if you miss that, then it's going to
consider that slash as part of the
characters
that you're looking at. And
>> that's where you got stuck because it
was at the end of the secret hash
>> and the secret hash readout was look was
was keying in was ending it the secret
hash readout was ending in a slash. If
you've looked at you know other people
who have done the lab so far
>> it would end that secret hash always
ends in an equal sign.
So this that's a quick tell. So now you
should be good.
>> Yeah. And then also like I should have
noticed that all of the other lines
ended with the backslash.
>> P we we're getting better at pattern
recognition. So it's not a problem. But
yeah, uh that the successful response uh
put that into this chat here and the uh
the end of Gche chat so that we can see
that you did the homework and you are
good to go.
>> All right. Thanks.
>> Yep. No problem. Uh Carlton, my fellow
American, you need to share your freedom
screen.
Let's see here.
Did that
uh
Colton,
I need you to share freedom screen.
Let's see
there. There's a freedom screen
and freedom of rings once again. All
right. So,
I see. Okay. Okay. So, where are you
stuck?
And if you're talking, we can't hear
you.
>> I am having issues today. Okay. Can you
hear me now?
>> Your freedom is ringing. So, yes.
>> All right. Cool.
>> Right.
So, this is my
This is how far you got,
right? Yes.
>> Okay.
Uh, now it's giving me an error.
Sorry, it's all over the place.
>> Um, you're only sharing uh the browser.
If you have a shell open, we can't see
it.
>> Okay, let me stop sharing and try to
share it again.
>> Okay.
Try to share the whole screen. Entire.
>> Yes.
>> Tell me if you can see my entire screen.
>> I think it's coming up now. should be a
shell my shell screen and okay
>> y
>> so
this was the command line I used
um I'm still at the uh beginning some
issue
>> oh I see I see what's going on okay okay
so
no option secret okay so you got your
secret on to verify secret hash for
better.
Okie dokie.
All right. So, first things first, I
want you to uh I want you to go back to
the browser and I'll point something out
for you.
>> Okay. So, we so the we got these
authentication flows. Okay.
And um I want you to click on each one
of them.
So, we'll I'll start with choicebased
sign in. So notice that this is uh allow
user o. Okay. So just keep that just
keep that in mind. Uh go to the second
one.
This is allow user srp. I have no idea
what that means but leave that alone.
Okay. Go to the third one.
And then allow refresh token a. So okay
that's the third one. So why does this
matter? Because uh if you go to your if
you go back into git bash and um your
the sessions that you tried previously
like if you just uh if you do the uh up
arrow to your last attempt.
So uh up hit up arrow again.
>> Yeah I did. It's just take it's
thinking. There we go.
>> Uh I see. So so you have oddflow here
right? So the odd flow ties back to the
authentication methods that you clicked
on previously. And right here it's
asking for user password option
that you could authenticate into your
user pool with. So let's enable that.
Okay. So click click on the browser
again.
and then click edit.
And now we have allow user password a
right here. So check that off. And then
uh also authentication flow since since
we're do so this is the bashes option
since we're doing a lab we want to max
this out. So make it 15 minutes.
That means that a session a session uh
key or a session uh value will last for
15 minutes while we're working this
stuff out. But if you want to make it
longer or shorter, then that's what you
that's what you do to change it. Uh then
save.
Okay. So now now we got four
authentication flows and then click on
username and password.
Yep. So now we're here. Okay. So now
with VAT with VAT uh let's try
authenticating.
Unable to verify secret hash for
client
blah blah. Okay.
Secret hash. Okay. So that's your client
ID.
And then the the client secret. We don't
need to worry about that's we only did
that when we were configuring the um the
hash. How about we try reconfiguring
that hash?
Okay.
>> Um, did did you did you get to configure
that hash by chance or No,
>> I don't think I did. No.
>> Okay.
>> I was I I had to step away from my desk
if I something. So, I just tried to
catch up as quickly as I could.
>> Gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. So,
uh
let's do this. So, I think Bash Bash
made a uh a quick script for Bash made a
quick script for you uh or for for all
of us actually.
Um but copy paste doesn't work on my
Zoom because it's Oh, [ __ ] It works for
you. Oh, no. No, it does not. Okay, I
got I got a link I got a link for you.
So, let's use this one.
Okay. So, and Bash, if you can throw in
your script, then that'd be cool.
>> Thank you.
>> So, Carlton, if uh open up the Zoom
chat, I put in a uh a link uh that
should say unable to verify secret hash.
>> Uh you may not be able to to copy it.
So, just going to uh
>> yeah, just it'll be you may just have to
just click on the hyperlink and then
copy it from wherever it opens up on
your machine.
You know what? I'll give you the uh
There you go.
Okay. So, yep. So this is what we're
solving for right now. So scroll down.
Okay. So this right here,
this is the contents of the file we're
going to create in order to
get the um the secret hash. So, all you
have to do is um copy everything here
that's that's boxed in and copy all
these lines and then save it as a Python
file.
They they refer to it as, you know,
secret_hash.py.
Doesn't really matter the name. It can
be whatever you want, you know. It could
be bald eagle, could be
uh
I don't know, diddy oil. I I have I
don't know. Could be whatever you want.
But basically, create create a file,
create a Python file or a file that ends
in py paste that content into that file.
And then what we're going to do next is
if this is number one then this is
number two. We're going to run this
command.
So
once that once that file is created then
open up git bash and we can uh go
through the the rigma roll.
>> All right. Give me a second.
>> Yep.
PS
open.
save and then I have to go and find it.
Correct.
>> Yep.
So this overrides the Okay. So, um, TIQS
instead of instead of that that script
overriding it like what we did in the um
what we did with copying the file, it
just makes a a regular a regular file.
What bashers command does
runs that just it's another way to run
that run the processes in a single line.
Um, so it there's mult multiple ways to
get the same same work done.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Um, it just prints it
to the CLI basically. So you can there's
multiple ways to skin a cat as they say.
>> Indeed.
There it is.
>> Okay. So, file created.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool. Now, now you can run the that
second command.
So
may have to run just Python uh Python
space and then the file name
and then uh and then you'll fill in the
username with your actual username,
the client ID with your actual client ID
and the client secret with your actual
client secret.
>> Okay. So um
Mhm.
>> So username is whatever you you set up
incognito.
Yep.
Then the secret is the secret.
Yep. Okay. And then copy that
that hash.
And one last thing I'll double check is
I would check the us. So the users
you've used the doc at at doc.cloud ops
I would verify that in the um
I would verify that in the user
management section. So users.
Okay. So you're right. I did that wrong.
>> Yeah. It it got tiqs so it can get us
all.
one second.
>> So,
>> so all you'll have to do is just redo
the hash with this new with this uh
username created
Yep. Yep. That's good.
Okay. So then next is just to redo my
command lines.
>> Yeah. So now so now we have the secret
hash.
Next we can do the initiate
authentication.
>> So do you do you have the initiate o uh
code block?
>> Yeah. Okay.
My scratch pad.
>> Oh,
>> actually I got another scratch. Hold on.
Make it easier cuz I'm all over the
place. Sorry. I was trying to catch up
so I just started doing [ __ ]
Not a problem.
So this is my username
super secret hash
It's my client radiating. Let's
try it.
Then it's the second one everybody.
Correct.
Okay. So we have So good. You got the So
the first part worked. Good. So you have
your challenge name and then you have
your session.
So you'll need that session code
uh for the you need that session token
for the next one for the next part.
>> Okay.
>> Do I need to put uh keep the quotes
around that session?
>> Uh no because this is uh this is working
in uh JSON. So this is this is JSON
output but what we're doing is straight
command line. So we don't have to follow
that uh that rubric. What you have in uh
in uh VS Code or what you had in VS Code
was good.
And then I need to use my uh MFA for my
coke, right?
>> Yes.
[ __ ] I forgot
it is not going to like these back
slashes. So, I need to do them real
quick. Sorry.
>> Nope. It's all good. It's all good.
>> For some reason, get bash back slashes.
It throws a fit. What was a fit?
All right. So before you uh uh can you
can we see your um your GI your VS code?
>> Uh yeah.
So, just so we can uh just so I can see
before anything happens. All right. So,
Yep. respond off challenge. Yep. Client
ID. Aha. Okay. So, so did what I wanted
to see. So, so we got challenge name.
Okay.
So, what's the challenge name here?
Right. So
the request so when you initiated the
authentication
these two have to match up if you want
to if you want the authentication to go
through
>> and the response we got was for software
token. So, um, so we can, so I'll just
switch out software token MFA for SMS
MFA or no, you know what I mean?
Yep. Okay. So, now you got challenge
responses, username equals blah blah
blah, right?
Uh,
okay.
All right. And you'll also need to take
a look at the at the documents. It'll be
helpful.
Uh, you know what? Let me just get the
the copy.
Uh, just get let's just get the link for
you.
There you go.
So, bam. Bam.
and Emerald said bam. Okay. So let's
look at this uh this the ways the wink
guy put in chat or respond to off
challenge
and
yeah you won't be able to write quick
copy but oh was he okay cool I I had to
open up in different I have more than
one browser open on more than one screen
and I just brought it over to the shared
screen so we can all see at the same
time four. Okay, so respond the off
challenge. So, uh, scroll down a bit and
we'll see synopsis. Okay, so scroll down
until So, this is good. We're good. So,
here, so here's how you can read the a
the command reference guide for AWS. So,
you have synopsis.
So,
in your mind, you can already say that
we're doing AWS,
right? That's one. And then the second
is what service are we using? So this is
cogto
dashp.
Okay. So so we're already doing AWS
cognto-idp.
So this third So the third portion
is this respond to off challenge.
Okay. And then everything underneath
here are
flags that we have to run. So we have
two ma. So every so how to read this?
Everything that's not inside of the
brackets
these are mandatory. So client ID is
mandatory and then challenge name is
mandatory
and then for our purposes
we'll also need um
where is session
>> at the top first one.
>> Oh well there you go. See your your eyes
are working. So session and then um this
one too challenge responses. So
basically, we'll need these top four
these top four in order to in order to
get this challenge to work or to
authenticate on the command line. Okay,
so
with that said,
uh we can start filling in some values.
Um and well actually uh yeah we we'll
start filling in some values. So
we have so you have your cogno respond
to off challenge. So you have your qu So
you do have a client ID
you have a challenge name.
>> Sorry too much.
>> Okay. No it's all good. It's all good.
So, so we have one,
you have two, you have three. That's
good. You have client ID, you have your
challenge name, you have challenge
responses,
and then you also have your session,
which is somewhere in the ether over
there.
Okay. Okay. Good. Then you have session.
So, for challenge responses, we we're
going to need more stuff because we cuz
right now we only have username. Okay.
Uh well, actually, we have username and
then we have MFA, but that's not the but
that's not the uh code that we that
we're going to use because we're using
software token that's aligning to um uh
SMS. So try
uh copying this block where it says
software token MFA. Copy that and then
uh paste paste and search for it on the
page. So copy software token MFA.
Okay. And then control F and search it
for it. Yep. Uh
okay. Go down. Uh keep searching down.
Oh, he get Yeah, the beautiful
beautiful. Here we are. It seems like
you already know what you're doing.
Okay,
so we have challenge. So, we have
challenge name softka
challenge responses username.
We have this bad right here,
which is good. Um,
okay. Yeah. So we have the username we
we have to copy this software token MFA
code. So this will replace the SMS code.
>> So just put code at the end of that
>> end of what
>> here?
>> Well,
where where is the MFA code uh where is
that being uh used in? So that that
software token MFA code that's being
used in the within the responses the
challenge responses.
So the challenge responses are right
here. So we need to get rid of this one
and put that new info right here.
So
right
it's got a match. So, software token MFA
code.
Yeah. And that'll just make it all caps.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Cool. So, that's
there. And then, uh, because we use a
secret hash, we also need the secret
hash to be within challenge responses,
right?
Um, so that should I go before sessions
or does it matter where I put it?
>> I'll put it I'll put it uh so after the
MFA code you can just do comma and then
uh secret uh hash similar to how it was
done up here. See how he did password
and then comma then secret hash. Same
way
repetition is the path to mastery.
So okay. So we have our updated
um software token MFA. We have the ch.
We have the appropriate challenge
responses.
We have the session.
I think we're good to give it a shot.
And like TIQS said, hopefully your 15
minutes didn't expire.
>> Probably.
Just being a It's just being a player.
That's all it is.
So
for my universe,
This hasn't started again.
Cool. Okay. New session.
This one.
Let's just do this. So,
Did you update your MFA?
>> Thank you.
>> That that gets that has gotten many of
us.
Yeah, that's smart. Waiting for a fresh
coke.
>> Yeah.
B get
this works.
Error. Uhhuh. And that that's what that
did previously. That's what I thought.
Okay. So I I know why it didn't work
because you have all these invisible
spaces or invisible enter marks here.
>> So So it's e it's an easy fix. It's
annoying, but we can just we can fix it
real quick. So go back thing to get
bash.
>> We're here.
>> Oh. Oh, sorry. Sorry, sorry. I mean, I I
misspoke. VS Code.
Yeah. So uh at the So you can go to the
beginning of each one and and press uh
backspace.
So start with start with B or yeah start
with three backspace
uh four backspace. Yep. You you know the
deal.
And if they do have a uh a dash, then if
they end up with a dash similar to this,
I will then that may be the the lines
where are continuing without you having
to interact with it.
>> Okay.
>> So, cuz that's happened to me.
>> So, just leave it. Correct.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Just leave it.
Yeah. And then uh the last one should be
B. See if see if you can uh
There you go. So yeah,
give that a shot.
code as well. You can do that by
pressing left. I mean, paste that and
then we can just change the code. That's
what I mean to say. You can just
>> say it again. I'm sorry, I didn't hear
you.
>> Um, the MFA code would have run out.
>> Just paste. Just paste. space for that
and then
uh what you can do is um
uh hold down the control key and press
the left arrow so you can speed through
the uh the um speed through the content.
Yeah, MFA is right here.
>> That is such a cheat code, man. I love
that.
D school is useful for useful for
something.
>> All right.
>> Okay. Fingers crossed. Let it rip.
Praise the name of Jesus.
>> Hey, Jesus delivered.
Man, your phone your phone's dancing
too. All right.
>> Right. Right.
>> So, you have done it. Good. So,
>> so this is good. So, now we can see the
parameters, authentication result, you
get your access token, expiry, the uh
refresh token, and ID token. This is all
important because when we start when we
start putting this into um because this
is the type of stuff that API gateway
will look at to verify that the request
is legit
and because we're setting it up in
cognto we're basically defining how API
gateway can def can refer to legit
content. So this is good. So, I would
say take a screenshot of this, put it
into this chat, put it into a geck chat,
put it both chats, and then now we now
you know how to do it, which is amazing.
>> Yeah, I'll be going back over this quite
a few times.
>> Yeah, like I [ __ ] the bed multiple times
doing this.
>> That's it happens to the best of us.
Just make sure you change the the sheets
afterwards.
Okay. Um
All right. So, at this point, good.
Does anyone have Is anyone else stuck on
this?
Feeling charitable today, so might as
well help people out. Um so, anyone else
stuck on this? If not, I can just then
we can just go through uh tear down and
then you guys have the rest of your day.
Okay. So, here
>> no no one with questions, no one with uh
uh config issues. We're good. Okay. So
what? So in order to uh delete in order
to tear this down cuz you will you will
get charged for this. So you'll get
traffic cognito. So what so what you can
do is um if you go to your
um
actually call to can you share your
screen if do you plan to keep this up or
do you plan to destroy it?
Uh, I'm planning on destroying it here.
I'll do a screen share and be getting
paid again.
>> Yeah, because I want I want you to try
one thing before I before you destroy it
because I think there's an easy way to
destroy this.
>> All right. Uh, let me know when you can
see.
>> Yep, I can see it. Okay.
>> All right. Cool.
>> So, I want you So, try clicking on your
user pools
here and then click Yeah. Click there
and then click delete. I want to see
this will tear everything down.
Yep.
Yep. Bam.
Delete.
Yep. That's it.
Easier than I thought. So yeah, user
pool's gone and you won't get charged.
You're good to go.
So that's it for tearown. So now
so yeah, if you guys want to run through
it, then feel free. Um today's Tuesday's
recording was a bit hectic. Yep. Just
use a pool. That's it.
And I want a screenshot of you guys
deleting the uh if if you guys are
tearing down, I want a screenshot in
just in this chat of the user pool not
being there any longer. Sweeney got it.
There it is.
There it is. Oh, look at that.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Parameterized all this
stuff. Cool. Works for me.
Good work.
>> Hey, Rob, do we get charged for user
pools and all that?
>> Yes, I I've I've gotten charged for my
user pool. Uh so, um I'm tell that's why
I'm telling you guys to tear it down.
>> Okay, good to know. Thank you.
>> No problem.
>> TQS. It was that simple. Like I I had to
rebuild mine three times and deleted the
user pool and it was just gone. So, I
was like, "All right, cool.
Sweenie, there it is. Bam. Okay, so
yeah, that's about it. Um, make sure to
post your evidence in the in the G check
chat saying that you did it. Um, tear
down is pretty simple. Um, yeah, that's
that's it for today. If you guys have
any other questions, then uh feel free
to ask. Otherwise, I'll
>> Is all we have to do just tear down our
user pool and that's it? Is there
anything else we have to do?
>> No, no, that's it. Just hit unuser pool
and it should stop the charges.
>> Okay. Thank you. Sorry about that.
>> No, it's all good.
>> Okay.
>> All right.
>> Yes. Good. Good.
>> All right. Thank you guys. Um, you guys
want to peek in on the 7.5, feel free.
Otherwise, you have the rest of the day.
Uh actually uh you guys well uh speech
ops at 6 uh unwind uh Saturday at 8 all
the times in Eastern so yep you got you
guys got options but as far as class
goes you guys are good. All right peace
out guys. Peace. Thank you Rob. Hey top.